hey what's up YouTube alright it is day
5 I have livestream 5 days in a row what
kind of person would do that you're
seeing it right now five days in a row I
am I've talked a lot this week but I
actually I've thoroughly enjoyed talking
to you guys and answering questions that
I've been skyping in Google hangout with
you guys and all kinds of stuff and
we've been raising funds for our new
studio which I'll talk about a little
bit but it's actually been really great
and this whole week and especially
everything with the election of elastin
bait and everything else it's like all
the stuff that I've been talking about
and classical liberalism and trying to
save the left from itself and being okay
with having conservatives and liberals
and anarchists and neo cons and
everybody that that's enjoying the show
at several different levels for all
kinds of different reasons it's been
pretty awesome so we're gonna do this
for a little bit and then I'm going to
do a patron only chat and a patron only
video stream on YouTube for anyone
that's on patreon normally it's 15 and
above but even if you do $1 or whatever
we'll get you on there for that we're
going to do that after this and I'm just
you can see I all week long I've been in
t-shirts just hanging around the house
I'm actually just coming back I did a
video with Praeger you so most of you
probably know who Dennis Prager is he's
a radio host and he said some TV shows
an interesting conservative commentator
I've actually I met him on Larry King's
show we were on once I was on as the
liberal he was on is the conservative
they wanted us to fight about a lot of
stuff but but we actually agreed and
came to agree on disagree on some stuff
really good guy so they wanted me in
there they do these interesting videos
on YouTube they did similar actually in
a way to some of the stuff we do I think
their tagline is Big Ideas small videos
or something like that or Big Ideas
short videos
anyway they wanted me to come on they
usually get conservatives on so they
wanted a liberal to come on and talk
about the regressive left tonight and I
did I haven't said much about the wreck
that's a word that I've sort of used
less lately but I I talked about that
and I enjoyed it I think it'll be up
soon they do some cool animation stuff
with it and it was fun being over there
they actually Ben Shapiro was there I
guess they share an office with daily
wire and and there were a bunch of you
know people who said they enjoy what I
do and
so it's nice to hear so uh all right so
we're doing this four and a half hour or
so maybe 40 minutes and I'm answering
questions right this has to be a half
hour because we're gonna do the patreon
thing right after and then I'm taking
off the weekend there will be no more
video streams this weekend I might even
not tweet this weekend possibly we'll
see about that what personal did you
know there was this huge I guess act
today or whatever half the internet went
down so Twitter was down what else was
down PayPal is down Netflix you read it
was down it was nuts but I have to say
not being on Twitter for a little bit I
felt like I was free I really I thought
Neil crash the matrix and I was like oh
my god we're all free we're gonna find
out the meaning life anyway so we are
raising funds for our new studio that's
what we're doing all week and it's going
great we actually so real quick I'll
just do some housecleaning and I'm happy
to answer some questions and stuff so
it's Rueben report calm / donate where
you can donate on PayPal er patreon
patreon calm / true but we have five
slots left it $100 level if you want to
be in the hangouts that we do the Google
Hangouts it's all video small intimate
ten or less people chats that we do
every month it's really cool we were
completely sold out of them so we opened
up ten more we only have five left right
now so I'd love to knock those out
tonight and then we'll do the patreon
chat after this and then yeah we'd love
to get 26 grand tonight the ultimate
goal is 30 but we're starting to double
content next week I'm giving live shout
outs by the way to anyone that donates
on either platform Ruben poor Tom /
donate live chat that's why you're here
alright so let's take some questions and
and then let's get the weekend started
who would I go straight for the running
joke between David and I is that we both
love to do megyn kelly I feel like it
would be like violent and weird I like
know so alright megyn kelly but that
one's kind of joke I like that what's
your name who's that girl that I like I
like that Amanda Peet I like Amanda Peet
there you go I'll do Amanda Peet okay I
mean I know that's getting close I'll do
a man to beat
that's week on the ribbon
replace the PBS pledge drive and if so
will you show the Nutcracker Romans ha
as the Reuben report plays replaced the
PBS Nutcracker drive you know it's funny
I I did a PBS fundraiser once when I
couple years into stand-up you know they
don't get like the most successful
people to do it they get some like
mid-level people and they called me in
and I did it with a comic actually it
was more successful than me a great lady
Kate Clinton was really one of the first
openly gay comedians really funny lady
and we did it at Caroline's comedy club
and we we hot tote bags and books and
all kinds of stuff but you know they
don't they don't have a lot of money in
there just raise a bunch so no we're not
gonna we don't plan on doing this maybe
after after today maybe we'll do this
once a year just to remind you know
refresh people of what we're doing but
no I don't want to do this all time whoo
by the way when we get the new studio
for sure we're gonna do a lot more live
streaming in general and hopefully we
can eventually livestream some of the
interviews and what live stream some
news stuff and some other ideas that we
have but we're not gonna be doing the
fundraiser thing so thank you for
bearing with me all week we appreciate
it and also you know we know that our
feet is [ __ ] up and YouTube has told
us that the feed is messed up and we
know that people are being unsubscribed
you too as YouTube has admitted it to us
privately they won't say anything
publicly they they tell us that it's
affecting other channels but they won't
say which ones I'm trying to pretend or
I'm trying to believe that it's not
politically motivated I don't really
know but anyway that's it that's all the
reet one of the reasons why being on
patreon to get press because you guys
allow us to do this without worrying
that you know we got to get every
freaking click so we don't have to click
bait and tag things the wrong way and a
lot of that shady [ __ ] that you know
many places are doing chimera that's a
good one I'm an atheist but what do I
think the role is of religion is in
society first off you know I know
there's several types of atheism and you
know the blending of the lines between
agnostic and atheism some people don't
see a major line between it like Peter
Bogosian who wrote a wonderful book
called the atheists
atheist guide to the universe how to
create an atheist oh my god a manual the
manual community thank you
my feeling about atheism generally is
that I just don't believe in something
without proof so if there was some
empirically provable a of proving that
some higher power was up there somebody
was watching me and care about sex I was
having what I was doing all day
conscious thing whatever then sugar
great I don't have any proof for that so
I try to find some principles to live my
life by that I try to live up to and I
sure I fail on them often but as far but
religion can have a very positive role
and go to most soup kitchens there being
people are doing it in the name of
religion go to go to your local church
or temple or whatever and you'll find
plenty of people volunteering and
raising money for sick people and you
know going to hospitals and helping
people and all kinds of stuff so I am
certainly not one of those people that
think that religion is is awful in all
cases I definitely am NOT expert a lot
of good into the world a lot of horrible
things have happened because of religion
to most reporters have some sort of
religious bent to them and I would be
for more things that bring us all
together the things that bring us apart
but I think there is a role for religion
within the idea that whatever it takes
for you to be a good person I would say
if religion helps you be a good person
or if secularism helps you be a good
person or I don't not I mean good like
morally good I mean just a productive
member of society I suppose or you just
don't have to member just donor people I
pretty much would be okay with you so
I'm definitely not I don't care what you
believe you could literally believe
anything in the privacy of your own home
and in your public life as long as
you're not trying to legislate my life
why would I care what you believe you
want to believe that you want to believe
in the Flying Spaghetti Monster go ahead
you know if I believe in anything it's
the force so you know that's it so do
you consider people like Steven creditor
and my love friends are they just folks
I like that one do you consider people
like Milo and crowd or friends or are
you just people that share of political
leaves or whatever so Milo I know Milo
personally a little better than I know
prouder Milo is you know come over here
and at dinner we got out we had a great
night at the Magic Castle which is a
really cool place where all these sorts
of magicians hang out
really a fun night and if you ever
wanted for the record if you ever want
to see Milo actually not my Louis taken
to a magic show because he loves magic
and he was very like but I genuinely
really do like both of them crabber I've
only met in person once and it was for a
few minutes but we we Skype sometimes
and talked about business and you know
some stuff we're doing I do like them
both
I know disagree I don't agree with both
of them on everything which of course
why would you ever have friends that you
only agree with that I agree with them
on so I would say I agree with Milo's
basic premise of what political
correctness has done to society and I
agree with that you know one of the
things that I've said about Milo many
times which is why I like doing videos
with him and I like to go to UCLA with
them and do a public stuff is that not
everyone like you guys watching this
right now are gonna you probably
appreciate a little more logical and
thinking things through
I think the UPS man right there and
having long-form conversation and really
unpacking an issue and all that Milo you
he throws out it purposely incendiary
things to get the conversation going and
whether you like those things or not the
fact is that that is how some people get
affected so when I was at UCLA with Milo
there were all these kids that were
coming up to me after that we're like
you know I really like what you're doing
with the show but they were like but
Milo is the one that brought me there
because he would say these crazy things
and I started following him and then I
came to you so I came to sort of
classical liberalism so that that's good
that's really good
someone like Crowder what do I agree
with him on you know I disagree with him
on about a lot of the social stuff I
think and probably some economic stuff
you know he's changed my feelings about
guns a little bit where I think maybe
before I knew him I was a little more I
would blame the gun violence on the guns
where I definitely don't do that as much
now I do that more as intent but either
way it's a moot point I mean it's it's
about it's about talking to people you
agree with and disagree with whatever
anyway since we know that our feet is a
little screwy if you guys want to share
this if you're on Twitter or Facebook or
you can share it to your own YouTube
is that a thing can that be done go
ahead anyway I'm given live shoutout
standing on the donates on PayPal or
patreon so it's your if you find any
work in what we do here and it's worth a
couple bucks a month to you to get some
of these ideas out there feel free to
jump in quick shout outs to Tyler who
just jumped in on patreon and Matthew he
just jumped in on patreon thank you
and we're 220 dollars away from 26
thousand a month and you're gonna help
build our studio and and I was actually
because I was just at a prank or you
place we're doing wiring I did all that
stuff over there they built a really
cool studio so I think we might learn a
little of how they built their thing to
build our things but I leave it in the
hands of amira who it's designed 87
studios for me in the last year and
reminder right after this at 6:20 it's
only 17 minutes from now we'll be going
live just for a small intimate thing for
all patrons normally is everyone at
fifteen we're gonna do it for everybody
just dollar or more whatever you throw
they're gonna go now I do get to see
you'll get to see him here last night I
did a patreon thing where I had David
and Mira take questions and fairly
people liked them more than me so how
have you changed over the years how am i
views changed over the years and which
is about the most I would say I would
say the thing that I've evolved most on
probably in the last in the last two
years let's say his number one is just
that because I was so in it with the
progressives I've always considered
myself liberal but I was obviously in it
with the progressive even though you can
go back and watch any video I ever did
on T YT like I wasn't I never with
somebody that always screamed racism or
bigotry or whatever but I'm sure I did
it at some love I have no doubt and
where I don't do that now not to say
that people can't be actually bigoted or
actually racist of course they can but
it's a it's a crutch and it's easier
what I'm what I now know very intimately
is that the reason they use those words
is because once you put that on somebody
you don't have to listen to why would
you ever listen to a racist argument
once you think they're racist so it's
really effective in silence and
conversation so that's one thing that
I've bought but I would say the other
thing I've involved on more so that's a
little more
like a little more tangible would be
generally taxes where I now really do
view lower taxes for pretty much
everybody and I might be for a flat tax
that has a slight increase when you hit
major you know you hit five million you
can pay more he attendant they were up
to twenty million where you can pay a
little more but that I would be for for
exempting a lot of very poor people for
taxes maybe under fifty thousand or
something nm everyone else paid fifteen
percent and that's it that's definitely
not a progressive value but I think that
is actually a classical liberal value
because it's about liberty so you should
earn and keep bonus for you and then
hopefully by you having more you'll hire
more you'll keep good for your community
and those kind of things so that's
something I've definitely shifted on
it's not thought of as a liberal
position I think but I think it actually
is a liberal position so I mean we know
you're a comedian but videos plans on
doing stand-up in the future are putting
up some here so I have one time there
were a lot of videos with me doing
stand-up floating around the internet
different places we did a pretty good
job with get it I'm taking them down
because my career kind of shifted and I
just felt that it would be better to
sort of relaunch in a different way one
day so I absolutely I'm gonna get back
to stand up and that what I mentioned we
did the live stream the other day is
that you know when I moved to I was
pretty I did stand-up for about twelve
years in New York and I was pretty
successful in New York and I rode gigs
worked with a lot of great comics I had
some success that got me on Sirius XM
and a bunch of other stuff and then when
I moved here to LA about three four
years ago I realized I was going to be
like at the low end of the totem pole
and I've already lived the life of a
struggling comic guy I spent years of my
life six nights a week sometimes two
hours and I can tie up ticket to Times
Square just like you get on stage and
rain or sleet or snow there was a night
that New York City had a massive
snowstorm one of the one of the coldest
nights in the history of New York City
and I was out there handing out tickets
and there was a winter advisory trying
to tell people not to be outside but you
know the tourists are still outside and
my friend called me because he said Dave
you're on ABC news right now I'm
standing in Times Square any tickets
because there's a guy out there telling
everybody to not be outside and I see
you behind him handing out tickets to do
a comedy show so I lose that light and
when I got here I was just like I don't
know if I want to do it again like it's
waste every
the comedy club enough to be there for
three hours to perform for 10 minutes
all that stuff but I do love stand-up
and I absolutely will get back to it and
now that my name has more value I can
actually draw so if I tweet it out and
I'm gonna be at the comedy sort of thing
people would show and then once you have
that kind of value then you're worth
more into the club if you have a little
more leverage so ideal I definitely will
get back into stand-up yeah we do
political stuff and social stuff
couple of quick shout outs Alec on
patreon and Chris on patreon thank you
guys welcome aboard live shout outs for
the next 13 minutes setting with the
joins on patreon or PayPal where $250
way from cracking 26,000 which would be
good for the night and then I can the
fundraising portion is over for now
Emira so T is in here
well sorry T I'm not fully on board your
Taxation is that thing I just sort of
laid out my my tax thing I would be for
exempting people basically under around
50 grand which is a lot of people then I
would have maybe something like a 15
percent flat tax to like 5 million
dollars and then maybe you up them maybe
you know 3% and then a 20 million
dollars you got them three percent of
then above 20 of them another 3 percent
something like that so that you can pay
a little more when you're really really
doing well create a little bit of a
social safety net for the people that
are struggling the most but I would want
something that basically is more fair
and T you got to admit for a liberal
that's pretty [ __ ] libertarian of me
maybe maybe not full on anarchy that you
want you know people punching monkeys
and robots in the middle of the street
but I think it's pretty good but you
guys should check out T's channel
how deep do I think they were aggressive
ideologies becoming in the gay community
hugely engrained which you know I live
in West Hollywood here's the gayest
place on earth you know in the two
blocks away from oh we get a rainbow
crosswalk it's pretty freakin gay and
unfortunately it really has but that
said there are a few people fighting
back a few well-known people Bret Easton
Ellis is a writer and a director he's
fighting back publicly against that I am
Peter Thiel you know The Advocate did
Abby absolute hatchet job on him the
other day basically saying he's not gay
because he's a trump supporter and what
what absurd regressive [ __ ] sorry
you're not gain for someone being gay
means you do one thing right you happen
to do it that makes you gay beyond that
whether I like the Golden Girls but
that's pretty much it you know I mean I
love sports and I love video games and
other stuff so the idea that you're not
gay anymore because you don't follow
this groupthink political stuff is
[ __ ] and that's become very
mainstream gay the Democrats really and
the regressives really have grabbed the
gays but I do meet plenty of games that
don't subscribe to this [ __ ] and a
lot of people that realize they better
wake up quick because you know my being
gay is supposed to be it's the other is
about $0.02 and pushing the limits and
being different and weird and
bah-bah-bah and I don't think even
though you can see these have different
weird I am but like you know I don't
think that's worth training so easily so
we got a we I hope that we'll be able to
wake up some people quick thanks to
Brian who just joined on PayPal thank
you sir everyone that joins is getting a
live shot up for the next couple minutes
and then we're going to patreon right
after this and if you just donate a
dollar on patreon you'll get that live
feed normally it's for fifteen dollars
and we got five spots open at hundred
bucks for our group google hangout which
i do once month small groups a video you
see everybody so you see people from all
over the world may see you we talk about
what kind of stuff Emira
what was the most annoying thing that
your guest is I mean it just so
completely the most annoying thing that
he gets to said or that I agree or
disagree was so completely let's see man
well I would say this Ben Shapiro
Bernard he's you know he's not for game
erage or or at least you know his
arguments kick it back to the states
like one of these arguments that I know
it makes sense in theory that should be
say it's right at issue or I get that
you guys know I'm for States right but
you know to sit across
from somebody who I was you know I you
know how I treat my I guess I go out of
my way to listen to them and understand
them and all that you know to sit across
from somebody who basically was saying
that you know my marriage doesn't add a
certain amount of morality to the
country or something to that effect I
don't want to misquote aamir but it was
I don't get offended that easily he
wasn't sending the Gestapo after me so I
wasn't offended but I was like it really
made me think wow here's someone who I
really like and respect even though I
disagree they're really thinks
differently than I do I would recommend
you guys so check that one out
alright I want to thank Brian on a
thousand a different Brian a different
Brian on PayPal who just donate $500
thank you Brian and Brian if you're if
you stick around after the patreon thing
I'll give you I'll do a quick like a
30-second thank you but then I have to I
have to head out for the night but I'd
be happy to thank you privately on Skype
real quick so thank you for that Brian
appreciate it you guys are help build
our studio it's it's pre sweet anyone
anyone who dumps jumped in at a hundred
on patreon will get a private thank you
from the odd Skype real quick tonight so
I do thank you guys and you're helping
build our studio we got a soundproof but
and wire it air-conditioned it and we're
gonna have a green screen in there we're
gonna desk area hopefully do some news
we're gonna have our normal interview
set a whole bunch of really we're gonna
really build out a cool kind of 360 we
got less than 10 minutes until the
patreon chat so just a couple minutes
more over here let's go to the
dispensary any recommendations I like
sativas the TVs are more in the body
high not the mental high oh I'm sorry I
like I like indica which is the body
high not the mental ice the team is the
mental how you can also get hybrids
which you're a literal vote so I like
granddaddy purple which you could take
one puff i I really would smoke that my
treat I smoked once a week maybe I take
one puff I lay on the couch and I watch
Seinfeld Simpsons that's coming so
that's what I like but it depends what
you like you know I'm friends with
plenty of comics who like to smoke
sativas and then run around and they're
productive and away from all of us what
do you live here a mirror-like sativa a
book
gelada that's that is the weed ice cream
yeah there's weed ice cream in my
freezer can I see it look this is snowy
so which we I mean here in LA where it's
legal its medicinal illegal I have a
license for it we're not doing anything
illegal here but you can get marijuana
in almost every form so this literally
is marijuana ice cream right here and
but how do you know how much to eat
before you're like whacked out of your
mud so it's a hundred milligrams I guess
you got to figure out what that means to
you but you can see I work a Mira
doing the week and then she eats her
marijuana and he's induced ice cream so
he can take that back
we're 201 away from the 26,000 I think
we can hit it I think we can get it
while we're here we have a special
person just donated on PayPal I want to
thank jank ogre that's right Jake Oh
Gert who just donated on PayPal and I'll
leave it at that
what's my solution to YouTube in
Facebook's attack on free speech okay so
uh look I don't know exactly what's
happening here but I do sense that
something may be going down again we
know that our videos aren't going out to
the feet as much that's why there's only
about 500 people in here when we have
almost 300,000 subscribers and I know
it's not going out two feet they've
acknowledged that they've also
acknowledged that people are being
unsubscribed from our channel and they
won't tell us why they won't tell us
other channels it's happening too but
they're telling us there's a bug now
it's possible that our channel is being
hit with the bug but Praeger you where I
just was and these are conservatives
they're pretty decent people a better
conservatives they're being hit with
stuffs being delisted and unn monetized
and a bunch of other things so it's not
purely censorship they're not deleting
videos but there could be something else
going on here I'm also pretty convinced
that Twitter's doing some sort of shadow
banding situation where there are people
that I just simply don't see their
tweets anymore so I based I haven't seen
a christina hoff sommers tweet in weeks
I barely ever see Chad's tweets anymore
I only see Sam's tweets occasionally
when he's retweeted so I do think
they're trying to shift us all into our
little into our little house
I don't know what they're doing but like
look if there's no direct evidence of it
what but then what I was to do but I did
DM like a couple influential people and
I said do you guys think this is
happening and everybody in there said
they thought it was happening quickly
want to thank David who just went up on
patreon thank you David and we got about
five minutes left and you're gonna get
to meet Amira and David in just a moment
and you know what we'll crack a model
sure we'll crack a bottle is Friday
night I'm taking them off the clock yeah
well you know what we could do it
something crazy if something crazy
happens on patreon okay file in the next
five minutes we do have a bottle another
no proven report bubbly but what would
that take okay give me another question
what an average citizen can do to
improve the mainstream media the most
important thing you can do is share
videos if you're if you don't want to
publicly talk about this stuff or
whatever you got to share these videos
whether they're my videos or someone
else's videos or whatever they are you
need to get these ideas out there and
everyone knows the Main Street is
crumbling but it's one thing if the
mainstream crumbles it's another thing
nothing decent is there to replace it so
we got to find a way to replace that
crap and Counting and is the answer
Trump TV the answer is probably not
Trump TV but I don't have an inherent
problem with Trump TV David said to me
literally a year ago he said that he
didn't think Trump wanted to be
President he thought he wanted to run
television he may be right you know let
it's officially known look if those if
Trump gets a challenge Milo gets on
there at certain [ __ ] at Scott Adams
and a bunch of other people I think that
would be fine absolutely no problem with
that whatsoever I would love to see a
channel that that was more about
classical liberal values and get people
out there that disagree on stuff
whatever I think that would be really
cool but the most important thing you
can do if you don't want to put your
voice out there yourself is share video
stuff again this is what the regressors
have done they have tricked good people
like you to think that if you post
something on your Facebook page that
people are gonna tell you you're racist
and you're Croson or bigoted just
because you think something different
about abortion or you think
taxes that's horseshit all right right
here I have a Reuben report bottle of
bubbly that has been ice-cold in the
fridge for a couple months now this was
sent to us by by a fan who runs a wine
distribution place he sent us a couple
bottles of different things but this is
Reuben Report bubbly there are only as
far as I know there are only two bottles
in existence we have both of them the
other one is away this is the one that
is killed and for what what would we do
to pop this open for everybody what do
you think it would take I mean it was a
hard bargain
we're $142
so can we push this thing to 6:30 okay
we're gonna push this thing to 6:30
we'll go 12 more minutes but we gotta
hit that we have Farley last $142 all
right $142 way on patreon from our
$26,000 goal and then we'll crack this
thing open why do you get a yeah then
you can ask them questions about me
right now so I'm confident this is gonna
happen so you can get the glasses and
now if you come but make make it happen
guys we've been working hard all week
actually a little bubbly does sound does
sound pretty good
we were thinking actually also up and
you know we're trying to figure out some
other ancillary ways to make some money
so that we're not so reliant on patreon
and we may do some like Reuben report
wine that we would sell through this
distributor who's a fan it would make a
fan fans business money you know we can
take just a little bit I'm not a huge
pumpkin guy don't love the pumpkin don't
look pumpkin spice I don't want it in my
coffee
there it is everything at Trader Joe's
pumpkin popcorn pumpkin
what no where was that that was here oh
it's really debate yeah yeah I don't I
just don't love pumpkins I like carving
a pumpkin David's an excellent pumpkin
Carver but it's a little gooey in there
how cancers are our comments are
incredibly incredibly but even the live
stream right now I'd venture to say that
they're pretty good I know I know
now I'm demanding the trolls do
something but you guys are really on
point and you're all over the place
politically and you're and it's
basically it's basically really good and
the responses that I get all day long
90% good there is this small group of
about 20 people mostly on Twitter who
really hate me and they they misquote me
all the time and do all sorts of
nonsense all the time to imply that I'm
something that I'm not or they lie about
me or whatever but for the most part
it's pretty good you know and that's the
thing like I go out of my way not to
demonize people that I disagree with
that's if you consistently lie about
somebody or or you consistently do
dishonest thing then I gotta call you
out on that [ __ ] but I try not to do
that as a general rule all right we just
got way closer Michael just joined on
patreon at 10:00
no good has been a big supporter who's
been part of this whole thing who pushes
me by the way on he sent me some private
stuff and he pushes me he just jumped up
on patreon 200 so I'll see you in the
Google hangout I'll see if I can push
you on something and guy Jim just joined
a Patriots actually I think those
numbers apparently we're still 142 but
we're gonna get there I have no doubt
you get there we will pop you will see
me pop champagne which I'm pretty pretty
good I'll see you're always not many
session thanks so many more back but
what is the point in its essence or
close what is the point the discussion
should close so I've only had
I'll tell you this there was somebody
that is in the public space that I used
to sort of be in the loop with it
doesn't matter who it's not someone that
I worked with at TYT I'll just put that
out there but there was someone in the
public space that I used to debate her a
lot sort of somewhat publicly and
privately we deem a lullaby and we once
got into a bit debate about something
and I thought that not only might win
the debate but I said after I was like
you know I said anything factually wrong
let me know and if I misrepresented
anything let me know about a lot he
couldn't get me on anything and but I
didn't feel like I convinced him of it I
felt like I just said things like he had
his opinion it just wouldn't accept
anything that I was saying even though
we couldn't disapprove anything I'm
saying so after that I sent him a few
articles furthering my point I said if
any of this is wrong let you know and if
you have anything you want to send me
let me know and I'll be happy to change
my opinion if you can prove it and
basically he said I don't want to
discuss this anymore you know how I feel
and that's that I thought I could this
is where that discussion is someone who
I've gone back and forth with for a long
time suddenly you found something that
we can't discuss anymore and it's
completely the reverse of your what I
think your your ethos is and that's
where it ends when it ends when you
can't get anywhere else but I would
always as a general rule I really really
try I told you guys I've had a couple
friends drop you over the last year even
someone in the last month I have nowhere
gay by the way who I guess felt that you
know I don't know I guess I'm anti-gay
when anti-gay bigot so you know you just
got to keep pushing you got to keep
pushing and saying what you think there
will be more of this believe me
every single one of you watching this
and all the people that I talk to you
we're ahead of the curve on this what
what America wants and forgets America
what the world wants and should not what
Trump and Clinton are offering us and
it's not what the media's offering us so
so there you go all right couple more
minutes we're gonna crack this bubbly if
we hit that 26,000 mark oh quick thanks
to Franz who just upped on patreon to a
hundred and will be joining us in the in
the group
we are 86 for $86 away on patreon there
you go and then we crack the bottle of
bubbly and then we'll talk to you guys
in the patreon livestream spots and and
then we stop doing our PBS style
promotions this was a week of it we got
a whole bunch of people to join and help
build out our studio and spread the
message and spread the word and it's
beautiful thing we do yeah we did there
to review a whole slew of other things
and hire far more people and really
really expand that's all right one more
that's a great question and it's very
much what I addressed today in the
preview video that I did it's funny
that's why they had me write a script
and then I went into preview they sat
down a big conference table about six
people all discussing my views of
liberalism classical liberalism and
their abusive conservatism and
bah-bah-bah and at one point I said in
my script I had said that you as a
classical liberal I said me is a
classical liberal I have more in common
with a libertarian then I do with a
progressive and then I think a couple of
them got a little surprised that I'd say
that because they think you know they
think of everyone on the left if you're
on the left you have more you would
progressive then the libertarian but a
cliff a classical liberal which google
it I mean it's about Liberty and it
could be jewel right since we demand
your responsibility for your life that
is far more to do with libertarianism
and I think in a lot of parts of Europe
they think the classical liberals and
libertarians are the same so it's partly
just how we define the word liberal here
in the States but I would - so I think
what was the question what do I have is
difference from yes so I would say sir
that I'm not a full libertarian and that
I believe that you know it depends what
your definition of libertarian is
because there are some libertarians at
the convention that don't think we
should have driver's license and want to
make arrowing legal and all kinds of
other stuff that I think is a silly
non-starter for a legit if you want to
be a real clue
I am for some social safety net I don't
want to redistribute all the wealth but
I want to people with the lowest I want
to do be able to help them in some way
but that means they can be also helped
privately too
so anyway so I don't think there's a
massive distinction between classical
liberals and libertarians and I think
that classical liberals and
conservatives are starting to come
together in a lot of ways too and I
think I could be a massive massive
successful political party if we had a
couple of good leaders I would love to
find someone that's thought of as a
little more liberal let's say a little
more okay with some social stuff to team
up with Paul Ryan who I think is a
pretty decent guy even if I disagree
with them on some stuff and start a new
political party I think that would be a
great movement one thing William who
just jumped in on patreon and Mark who
just upped on patreon were $77 away but
we have to start the patreon thing soon
but we're gonna know Amin got his car
Amit Amit got his in a car accident
anemia stay home what she watch that's
not Star Wars well it depends what you
had is this Netflix or what do you got
so orange in the new black which I just
watched last season on Netflix was
awesome I know I'm late on that West
world West world we just started on HBO
which is fantastic yeah we watched
mascots last night on Netflix which is
done by the Christopher Guest people
that did Best in Show and waiting for
Guffman and my tea window and it sucked
it was such a you see it yeah it was
such a ripoff of their own [ __ ] so it
was terrible what else is on oh you know
what if you have Netflix watch Black
Mirror which there's a new season coming
out there's about eight out already but
it's on Amazon price okay so I'm that
one totally sure where it is but it's
about the future but only like three
years in the future so you see like
weird technological things that actually
feel like they could happen tomorrow
it's very cool
all right a live shadow it's raining
with its left
let's crack the rare bottle the one of
only two in the world of Rubin report
bubbly anyone enjoy nature anyone that
joins on patreon right now is going to
join us for for the drinking of this but
if I hate IT back IT the updates budget
he's redistributing wealth that
hypocrite thanks brother all right where
we at
we do take Bitcoin but money out t cry
oh I asked him about that yeah what's
your reason for mother's choice as far
as constant contraception axonal
pregnancies finger toes should taxpayers
have to fund it this guy is kind of
agnostic about his children around and
he PS I'm one of morally support ending
their life as a reasonable solution so
we've talked about abortion a bunch
basically the question is he the person
who asks is basing it that's the matter
but what do we do
related to you know people that are
using it as contraception and a series
of other things so look as I tweet it
out I am NOT I don't love the idea of
abortion I know people that have had
abortions that it is not an easy thing
for any woman to do obviously but the
reason that I'm pro-life is I would not
want to tell a woman what to do with her
body period that would be for me
personally that said you get to a point
when I never do it the cosmic stew that
is inside there when that starts
becoming a viable life and what do you
do is it the right of the state to say
can I do something with your body or is
it the right of the state to say you
must go through with this pregnancy I
think that's an interesting
philosophical argument so I would be for
the right to choose but then at some
point and this is where scientists and
philosophers and politicians would after
they really get together and figure out
the point of sort of no return but then
does the state have any right does the
state have any not right but is there is
it incumbent upon the state then to help
someone that is going to be forced to go
through with the pregnancy and can we
do more to help with adoptions and all
kinds of other stuff so it's a really
complex issue and I think they actually
believe it or not I think Trump and
Clinton did have a somewhat healthy
discussion about it and you know Clinton
obviously is very very pro-choice
Trump's argument which I don't even
think he's really pro-life but I think
he's pandering to the right on this but
his argument was flipper oh wait not to
make abortion illegal but to boot it
back to the states but you know that's a
slippery argument that as I said earlier
with ben shapiro in gay marriage you
know and everyone picks their first
dates rights for certain things but not
for other things all right I'm ready to
drink some bubbly I think by the way
we're really close right now Philip just
jumped in on patreon and Michael just
jumped in on a towel so we're very close
to cracking the bubbly so let's not have
this thing warm up people we've already
passed at 6:30 like the paper on people
so what
to what extent should state government
to protect their citizens from from the
federal government you know as I've said
a couple times here I'm for states
rights I would want to be governed
locally it's more important here in West
Hollywood I would want my room mayor
like both Wharton I think lids kind of
near me like within walking it since I
would want him to have more control over
my life than I would have some
bureaucrat in Washington so I think
local control is generally good for
states right you know so I would be I
would be leery of the feds imposing
anything on States now I know what some
of you were saying Dave you just said
that the roe v-- wade then you you're
okay with that and yeah this is one of
those things where everyone sort of has
maybe I have to flesh it out a little
bit more I think it would just be
dangerous if suddenly 40 states suddenly
said no abortion is illegal I think that
would be a problem and I don't think it
would stop poor people I don't think it
stopped rich people from getting
abortions by the way I thank you anyone
not as way we're $41 weight I think it
would stop poor people from getting
abortions and then it becomes a class
thing too so there you go I remember
somebody to ratify we got to say cracker
what do you need right now people I want
to practice thing drink it jump over to
picture I got to get out of here by like
7:05 anyway so yeah so we got to start
the exclusive screen oh you know what
all right
someone do it someone's going to do it
right now we're gonna crack this I'm so
the pledge that puts us over is going to
get a personal thank you for me Skype
which will either do tonight over the
weekend and all right Mira what do you
got
I'm gonna I'm gonna start with this
preparation only to plunder $41 all we
need is a pledge over $41 on patreon we
just got and we just got it who did it
gene all right gene G with the G so that
is a man I believe Thank You gene and
thank all you guys for playing along all
week and this would be a nice way to to
wrap up the week and a shout out to
Morgan bubbly yeah and you know when
you're pouring a string you have the
board really to the side to make sure
that it doesn't have to talk like that
when you're doing it you know all right
very good you can pour the earlier those
will do a quick toast for everybody here
Amir I'll take one last question here
and then we're gonna jump over to pay
chat and thank you guys for everything
all week it's been that it's been kind
of exhausting and I had so many other
things going on in terms of having a
meet contractors and a bunch of all
kinds of business stuff attacks loan
stuff and crazy stuff but I really
appreciate everything you guys
everything you guys have done for us to
build this thing and trust me we're just
at the beginning but this this is the
beginning you know before we were at the
beginning of the whole thing now we're
at the beginning of what really is going
to
this thing out of the water with the
home studio there's nothing we won't be
able to do last question worried that
the Indian ah a British guy who wants to
move here who's worried that the Indian
food won't be good there are a ton of
great Indian places I used to really not
like Indian food but I've come to really
like it David it's actually his favorite
cuisine to eat you could see some of the
things we're eating at an Instagram it's
David's cookbook is his handle earlier
but you'll find plenty don't worry it
wasn't the champagne but Amira did just
spill coffee all over the place alright
so well they could all right now you can
see you get a bonus minute because all
right we gotta go so here we go guys you
know what I'm gonna you guys clean up oh
yeah okay so we're gonna do it on the
Patriot Street you just have to put a
dollar in and gently shadow to Sean Sean
and Caleb Thank You Callie sorry thank
you guys thank you everybody for
everything all week and my phone may
have been destroyed in the process of
this coffee all over my shoe and all
right thanks guys have a great weekend
at Lake